>> LET'S TALK TO GRANT WAHL,
FOUNDER OF GRANTWAHL.COM.
HE WAS DETAINED JUST FOR WEARING
A SHIRT WITH A RAINBOW ON IT.
GRANT, I'M SORRY THAT HAPPENED
TO YOU.
I THINK EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF WHAT KAITLAN SAID ABOUT
THIS RULE OF FIFA THAT THIS IS
HYPOCRISY?
>> I THINK HE MAKES A POINT WHEN
HE TALKS ABOUT 3,000 YEARS DOING
BAD THINGS.
I THINK EVEN THE U.S. HAS A FEW
THINGS LIKE THAT IN ITS HISTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE FIFA
PRESIDENT WHAT HE TOOK THAT TO
MEAN, I THOUGHT, WAS REALLY
OUTRAGEOUS, ACTUALLY, THAT JUST
BECAUSE OF THAT HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS IN AUTHORITARIAN
COUNTRIES LIKE HERE IN QATAR,
THE OUTLYING OF HOMOSEXUALITY,
THE TREATMENT OF MIGRANT
WORKERS, ALL OF THAT, IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE ACCORDING TO THE FIFA
P
PRESIDENT TO CRITICIZE THAT
WHICH I THINK IS JUST WRONG.
IN TERMS OF MY SITUATION BEFORE
THE U.S. GAME, I WAS TOLD BY
FIFA AS I SAID PUBLICLY AND ALSO
BY U.S. SOCCER, WEARING A
RAINBOW SHIRT, WEARING A RAINBOW
FLAG WOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM HERE
IN QATAR, FIFA WAS GOING TO MAKE
SURE IT WAS NOT AN ISSUE FOR
FANS OR ANY VISITORS.
I SHOWED UP AT THE STADIUM AND
INSTANTLY, I WAS PUSHED ASIDE BY
SECURITY GUARDS AT THE MEDIA
ENTRANCE, I WAS TOLD EXPLICITLY,
YOU NEED TO TAKE OFF YOUR SHIRT.
THAT'S A POLITICAL STATEMENT,
AND YOU CANNOT ENTER BECAUSE OF
THAT.
I REFUSED TO TAKE OFF MY SHIRT.
I DID GET A TWEET OFF,
THANKFULLY, ABOUT IT.
I WASN'T REALLY PUTTING OUT
PUBLICLY THAT I WAS WEARING THE
SHIRT UNTIL I WAS DETAINED.
THEY FORCEFULLY TOOK MY PHONE
OUT OF MY HANDS FOR 30 MINUTES.
THEY MADE ME STAND IN FRONT OF A
CCTV CAMERA.
THEY CONTINUED TO TRY TO GET ME
TO TAKE OFF MY SHIRT.
THEY STOOD ABOVE ME AS I SAT AND
ANGRILY YELLED AT ME.
ONLY AFTER ABOUT 30 MINUTES DID
A COMMANDER COME DOWN AND LET ME
THROUGH, WEARING MY SHIRT.
AND HE APOLOGIZED, AS DID FIFA.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT AGAIN?
>> I PROBABLY WILL.
I HAVE GOT MY SHIRT.
AND I HAVE NO FEAR HERE.
ABOUT ANY OF THIS, IT'S BEEN A
WEIRD WEEK, I MEAN, LITERALLY,
IN ACCREDITATION LINE, WHEN I
GOT HERE, I TOOK A PHOTO, A VERY
INNOCUOUS PHOTO, OF THE WORLD
CUP SLOGAN ON THE WALL.
THERE ARE NO SIGNS PROHIBITING
PICTURES, A SECURITY GUARD CAME
OVER AND SAID NO PICTURES AND
DEMANDED THAT I ZLDELETE THE PHO
FROM MY PHONE.
>> GRANT, WHAT IS IT LIKE, YOU
WERE PULLED OVER TO THE CCTV,
AND HARASSED OVER THE SHIRT.
HOW WERE PEOPLE AROUND YOU
RESPONDING?
>> A FRIEND OF MINE FROM "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" TRIED TO HELP
AND GOT DETAINED AS WELL FOR A
LITTLE BIT.
YOU KNOW, I WAS THINKING THE
ENTIRE TIME, LIKE IF I'M BEING
TREATED THIS WAY, DURING THE
WORLD CUP, WHEN THE ATTENTION OF
THE WORLD IS ON QATAR, I'M AN
AMERICAN WHO HAS A PRETTY
PROMINENT MEDIA FOLLOWING,
IMAGINE HOW GAY PEOPLE, IN
QATAR, OUTSIDE OF WORLD CUPS
MUST FEEL AND WHAT THEY MUST
ENDURE.
AND THAT'S A LOT TO THINK ABOUT.
>>> SECRETARY OF STATE TONY
PLINKEN IS CRITICIZING
INTERNATIONAL SOCCER GOVERNING
BODY FIFA FOR THREATENING WITH
YELLOW CARDS IF THEY DARE TO
WEAR WHAT YOU SEE, A ONE LOVE
ARMBAND SUPPORTING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION.
I'LL PLAY FOR WHAT YOU SAID
ALONGSIDE HIS COUNTERPART THIS
MORNING.
>> IT IS ALWAYS CONCERNING FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE WHEN WE SEE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION, ESPECIALLY SO WHEN
THE EXPRESSION IS FOR DIVERSITY
AND FOR INCLUSION.
AND IN MY JUDGMENT, AT LEAST, NO
ONE ON A FOOTBALL PITCH SHOULD
BE FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING THESE VALUES AND
PLAYING FOR THEIR TEAM.
>> AND THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE
LATEST OF SEVERAL CONTROVERSIES
THAT HAVE BEEN OCCURRING IN AND
AROUND THE WORLD CUP IN QATAR.
JOINING ME NOW IS ESPN
COMMENTATOR PATRICK McENROE AND
CHRISTINE BRENNAN.
IMPORTANT STUFF TO TALK ABOUT
AND WE'LL GET TO THE SPORTS IN
JUST A SECOND.
CHRISTINE, YOU HEAR BLINKEN'S
REMARKS THERE.
TEAMS NOW NOT WEARING ONE LOVE
ARMBANDS BECAUSE FIFA THREATENED
THEM AND YOU HAVE GRANT WALL, A
WELL-KNOWN SPORTSWRITER TELLING
CNN HE WAS ZDETAINED AND BLOCKE
FROM WEARING A RAINBOW T-SHIRT.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENED.
>> INSTANTLY I WAS PUSHED ASIDE
BY THE SECURITY GUARDS AT THE
MEDIA ENTRANCE AND I WAS TOLD
EXPLICITLY THAT YOU NEED TO TAKE
OFF YOUR SHIRT.
THAT IS A POLITICAL STATEMENT
AND YOU CANNOT ENTER BECAUSE OF
THAT.
I REFUSED TO TAKE OFF MY SHIRT.
AND THEY STOOD ABOVE ME AS I SAT
AND ANGERRY YELLED AT ME.
ONLY AFTER ABOUT 30 MINUTES DID
A COMMANDER COME DOWN AND LET ME
THROUGH WEARING MY SHIRT.
AND HE APOLOGIZED AS DID FIFA.
>> CHRISTINE, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF ALL OF THIS?
THAT LEVEL OF ATTEMPTED CONTROL
AT A SPORTS EVENT SEEMS SMALL.
>> IT IS TERRIBLE.
PATRICK AND KATE, GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU, BOTH.
AND BUT IT IS TOTALLY
PREDICTABLE.
FIFA, THERE IS NO ONE THAT
DESERVED THIS KIND OF FIASCO
MORE THAN FIFA.
FOR GIVING THE WORLD CUP TO
QATAR BACK IN 2010.
WE COULD HAVE TELEGRAPHED ALL OF
THIS EVEN THEN.
AND IN FACT THE STEADY DRUM BEAT
OF CONTROVERSIES AND THE STORIES
OF THE MIGRANT WORKERS AND THE
CONCERN NOW OBVIOUSLY APPARENT
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED OVER LGBTQ RIGHTS.
AND HOW QATAR AND FIFA WOULD
HANDLE THAT.
THIS IS A CATASTROPHE, FRANKLY A
PR CATASTROPHE OF THEIR OWN
MAKING.
THEY DESERVE THIS.
AND INSTEAD OF TALKING SOCCER
AND SPORTS, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS AS WE SHOULD BE.
THE CONTROVERSY ABOUT THE
ARMBANDS, WHAT THEY WERE SAYING
WHAT FIFA WAS SAYING AS MANY NOW
KNOW IS THAT IF YOU WEAR THE
ARMBAND, THAT WOULD BE ON THE
CAPTAIN, IMMEDIATELY THAT HE
WOULD GET A YELLOW CARD.
AND IF YOU GET TWO OF THOSE,
YOU'RE OUT OF THAT MATCH AND THE
NEXT MATCH AND YOU'RE TEAM PLAYS
ONE PERSON DOWN.
I SO WISH THAT THE EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES HAD TOLD FIFA TO GO
JUMP IN A LAKE.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO WAY THAT
FIFA COULD HAVE ACTUALLY -- THEY
COULD HAVE GONE AHEAD WITH IT
BUT IT WOULD HAVE TAINTED THEIR
ENTIRE TOURNAMENT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING.
AGAIN, THIS WAS TOTALLY
PREDICTABLE AND IT IS TOTALLY
DESERVED.